♪ ♪
>> Bret: WELCOME BACK TO
"SPECIAL REPORT" FROM NEW YORK
TONIGHT, OHIO CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN IS THE TOP REPUBLICAN
ON THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTE
COMMITTEE, ALSO SERVES ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
HE JOINS US LIVE FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
I WANT TO START GET YOUR
ASSESSMENT ON THIS DAY, THIS
TRANSCRIPT AND WHERE THINGS
STAND TONIGHT.
>> THIS TRANSCRIPT IS THE REASON
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH IMPEACHMENT, IT
JUST SHOWS YOU THIS IS NOT ABOUT
FACTS, THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
TRUTH, THIS IS JUST A PRETEXT
FOR THEM TO DO WHAT THEY'VE
ALWAYS WANTED TO DO.
THEY'VE BEEN INVESTIGATING GOING
AFTER THIS PRESIDENT SINCE
JULY 31ST 2016 AND THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR ANYTHING THEY CAN
HANG THEIR HAT ON BECAUSE
REMEMBER, THE MICHAEL COHEN
HEARING WAS A FLOP.
THE JOHN DEAN HEARING WAS A
FLOP, THE BOB MUELLER HEARING
WAS A FLOP.
THE MUELLER REPORT WAS A FLOP,
THE LEWANDOWSKI HEARING WAS A
FLOP SO THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT, MAYBE THIS TRANSCRIPT.
BUT EVEN THEY HAVE SAID THERE
WAS NO PRICK, QUID PRO QUO.
THE CHAIRMAN THEMSELVES HAVE
SAID THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO
HERE, THERE WAS NO TALK ABOUT
HOLDING UP FOREIGN AID FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
IT.
ZELINSKI, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UKRAINE, SAID HE WASN'T PUSHED,
SO THIS IS JUST A DEMOCRAT OUT
TO GET THE GUY WE ELECTED
PRESIDENT, PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
>> Bret: HERE IS A COMPILATION
OF SOME OF THOSE DEMOCRATS TODAY
AND YOU RIGHTLY POINT OUT THAT
IT DEPENDS ON WHICH PRISM YOU'RE
LOOKING THROUGH HOW IT WAS
PERCEIVED OF THIS TRANSCRIPT,
AND HERE ARE THE DEMOCRATS.
>> WHEN YOU ASK SOMEONE TO DO A
FAVOR, YOU OWE THAT PERSON
SOMETHING IN RETURN AND WHEN
THAT PERSON IS A FOREIGN LEADER
OR THAT MEANS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES ONE DAY YOU
WILL HAVE TO PUT A FOREIGN
LEADER'S INTEREST AHEAD OF
AMERICAN INTERESTS.
>> THIS IS A POWDER KEG.
>> COERCING A FOREIGN LEADER
INTO DIGGING UP DIRT AGAINST A
POLITICAL RIVAL FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S POLITICAL GAIN TO
WIN REELECTION.
>> EVEN IF THERE WERE ABSOLUTELY
NO INSTANCES OF QUID PRO QUO,
THE DEMAND ITSELF IS A BETRAYAL
OF THE PRESIDENCY AND THE MISUSE
OF THAT OFFICE AND ANY USE OF
THE PRESIDENCY FOR PRIVATE,
PERSONAL, POLITICAL GAIN IS A
VIOLATION OF HIS OATH AND NOT TO
BE IMPEACHABLE AS AN OFFENSE.
>> Bret: YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THERE'S JUST ONE PROBLEM WITH
ALL THAT, BRET.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE
SAID TODAY THAT HE WASN'T PUSHED
AT ALL IN THAT PHONE CALL.
HE SAID HE WANTS TO DRAIN THE
SWAMP IN THE UKRAINE JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DRAINING THE
SWAMP HERE, SO THE DEMOCRATS CAN
SAY ALL THEY WANT -- HERE'S WHAT
WE KNOW.
HERE IS WHAT WE KNOW.
THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER DIDN'T
HAVE ANY FIRST-HAND KNOWLEDGE OF
WHAT TOOK PLACE, WASN'T ON THE
CALL.
I BET THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER HASN'T
EVEN SEEN THE TRANSCRIPT UNTIL
TODAY, BUT WE DO KNOW THIS ABOUT
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, HE HAD A
POLITICAL BIAS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TOLD US
THAT.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS WE KNOW.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER GOES TO THE
IG TO TELL THIS
INSPECTOR GENERAL, HE LOOKS AT
THIS, KICKS IT UP TO THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE SAYS THERE'S
NOTHING THERE, SO WHAT DOES THE
INSTRUCTOR GENERAL DO?
HE GOES AROUND THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND SENT A
LETTER TO ADAM SCHIFF TO CREATE
THIS CRAZY ORDEAL WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS
IN THE DEMOCRATS CAN SAY ALL
THEY WANT BUT IT DOESN'T SQUARE
WITH THE FACTS, IT DOESN'T
SQUARE WITH WHAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UKRAINE SAID TODAY.
>> Bret: HERE'S WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING, CONGRESSMAN, AND THAT IS
THAT IF IT WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA,
YOU WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT TUNE
TONIGHT.
IF IT WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA
TALKING TO A LEADER FIRST ABOUT
MILITARY AID AND THEN SAYING CAN
YOU DO ME A FAVOR TO INVESTIGATE
JOHN JR. AND HIS BUSINESS
DEALINGS, THAT YOU WOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH ALL OF THAT.
WHAT'S THE RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> THE DIFFERENT TUNE IS THE
DEMOCRATS.
JOE BIDEN'S SON -- JOE BIDEN'S
SON GETS PAID $50,000 A MONTH
FOR SEVERAL YEARS TO WORK FOR A
COMPANY IN AN AREA OF THE
INDUSTRY THAT HE HAS NO
EXPERIENCE IN.
AND THEN WHEN THERE'S A
CORRUPTION INVESTIGATION INTO
THE COMPANY HE WORKS FOR, GUESS
WHAT, HIS DAD, WHO HAS A PRETTY
IMPORTANT POSITION IN OUR
GOVERNMENT AT THE TIME,
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS EITHER
YOU FIRE THAT GUY WE ARE GOING
TO HOLD UP AID.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE
CHANGED THEIR TUNE, NOT US.
50,000 BUCKS A MONTH AND I'VE
GOT PEOPLE I GET THE PRIVILEGE
OF OUR PRESENT AND WHO DON'T
MAKE THAT IN A YEAR.
THIS GUY GETS IT EVERY MONTH FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND YOU DON'T
THINK THAT'S STRANGE?
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO HAVE THE
DIFFERENT TUNE, NOT REPUBLICANS.
>> Bret: IT WHERE YOU THINK
THIS GOES?
THERE WAS ONE REPORT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE 213 VOTES.
THEY NEED 218.
TO THINK A FORMAL INQUIRY TURNS
INTO IMPEACHMENT ARTICLES?
>> LOOK, YOU HAVE TO ASK THEM.
ALL I KNOW IS THIS IS A
FULFILLMENT OF WHAT
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID WE ARE BACK
ON JANUARY 3RD 2017.
HE SAID TO PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP, HE SAID IF YOU MESS WITH
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THEY
HAVE SIX WAYS FROM SUNDAY AT
GETTING BACK AT YOU.
THEY STARTED DOING THAT CLEAR
BACK THE I BELIEVE IN JULY OF
2016.
CONTINUE TO DO IT.
I THINK THIS IS JUST ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF THOSE SIX WAYS -- I
THINK NOW MAYBE IT'S MORE THAN
SIX WAYS, FRANKLY, THAT THEY
POINT AFTER THIS PRESIDENT.
TWO THEY HAVE THE VOTES?
YOU HAVE TO ASK NANCY PELOSI.
IT APPEARS THEY MIGHT BUT I KNOW
THIS, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK
IT'S RIDICULOUS, THEY THINK IT
IS COMPLETELY UNWARRANTED, NO
JUSTIFICATION FOR IT AND I THINK
MOST AMERICANS ARE PLEASED WITH
THE JOB THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE
IN LEADING OUR COUNTRY THESE
PAST THREE YEARS.
>> Bret: WHAT ABOUT THE JOB
RUDY GIULIANI IS DOING?
HE DOESN'T WORK FOR THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT BUT HE IS OBVIOUS
THEY WERE REPRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT AND INVESTIGATING,
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> IT'S UP TO THE PRESIDENT, THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF, IF YOU WANT
SOMEONE TO REPRESENT THEM IN
CERTAIN AREAS UNDER CERTAIN
TASKS, THAT'S UP TO HIM.
ALL I KNOW IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS TRANSCRIPT, TO THINK THAT
NANCY PELOSI DID A PRESS
CONFERENCE FOR WHAT WAS IN THAT
CALL, WHAT WAS IN THAT
TRANSCRIPT AND THEY GOT ALL
THESE DEMOCRATS NOW SAYING THEY
ARE GOING TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT BASED ON THAT, YOU'VE
GOT TO BE -- WHEN EVEN
JERRY NADLER AND ADAM SCHIFF IN
THESE DEMOCRATS SAY THERE WAS NO
QUID PRO QUO IN THAT TRANSCRIPT,
EVEN THEY SAY THAT, YOU KNOW
THERE'S NOTHING THERE, BUT FOR
THESE GUYS, IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IF THEY ARE OUT TO GET THIS GUY
AND I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE THROUGH IT.
>> Bret: CONGRESSMAN, YOU'RE
SURE IN YOUR MIND THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BACKFIRE ON DEMOCRATS?
GO WE WILL LEAVE IT UP TO THE
PEOPLE BUT I KNOW THE FOLKS IN
OHIO THAT I GET THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING AN ALL AROUND OUR
GREAT STATE, THEY UNDERSTAND A
GOOD JOB PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DOING AND THEY SUPPORT HIM AND
IF THE ELECTION I THINK WERE
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD WIN